hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's Legend of Korra Q&A and a
lot of big questions about what's going
on with Korra and her head totally got a
lot of problems to work out just
remember we're barely halfway through
book four so Korra has a little ways to
go before she finds the right path
careful for spoilers if you're not
caught up on book four but starting with
question number one
Isabelle ass do you think that news of
Varrick and Bolin's death will spread
tamaco and Asami no I think that
everyone's gonna meet up before that I
think that Bolin and Varrick are gonna
head back to friendlier territory
whenever meelo and Ikki rode in with the
sky bison to save Korra
they took off they're not sticking
around xiaofu so I think that they're
heading back to air temple Island I
think it'll take Bolin and Varrick a
little bit longer to get back but I
don't think they're gonna be lost
wandering around the earth Kingdom on
their own I think they will head back to
Republic City to question number two
larysa asks what do you think the kuvira
was going to do to Korra when she had
her trapped I think she was totally
gonna kill her if you remember in the
first episode from book 4 when we first
saw kuvira going crazy with those metal
bands on her armor she was just
capturing people even though metal can
be made to be very sharp so she could
have just killed all those bandits it's
hard to tell what kuvira's plans are for
the avatar in general the weapon she's
replicating has the power of an avatar
or dark avatar depending on how you look
at it so Korra would be the only thing
able to fight that it's possible she has
some secret plan for Korra that we just
haven't learned yet question number
three Nick asks do you think that Kabira
is like an avatar universe version of
Hitler I definitely think she's a
fascist so I would say yeah plus if you
look at a lot of her troops visually
they're inspired by a lot of the Nazi
storm troopers you could also say Star
Wars stormtroopers but I think there's a
stronger link to traditional fascism the
next step would be her kicking everyone
out of the earth Empire that doesn't bow
down to her like expelling them from her
boarders and if you haven't studied
World War 2 yet concentration camps used
to be called re concentration camps
which sounds a whole lot like
re-education camps very sinister so yeah
things are only getting worse with
kuvira she's only becoming more and more
like Hitler every day question number
four Sid as there's been a lot more
focus on the Airbender children recently
do you think that look at their own
comic book eventually I don't know if
they get their own comic book title in
the near future but I think that Nick is
exploring all possible licensing
Avenues so you might see a mobile game
or special merchandise in terms of the
comics specifically you probably just
see small adventures inside of larger
stories so if they did a core comic book
in a couple of years you'd see like a
couple pages with just the Airbender
children going off doing something on
their own but it would happen inside of
a Korra comic it's possible they could
branch out in the future but for now the
comics are just gonna focus on the main
protagonist mostly team aang and then
once the Korra comic comes around team
Korra characters question number five
Roger s why didn't Korra metalbend again
Scooby rub well I think she just really
offer game it's been three years
remember add to that the Korra didn't
become an expert at metal bending before
she went into hiding before she went
away for three years so she's really not
super hot at any type of bending she
just hasn't been in training if you
remember before book 1 before she moved
to air temple Island she was in secret
training in the Southern Water Tribe
she basically been doing nothing but
training that whole time if she had done
that I think the battle would have gone
very differently I think in having her
lose what Mike and Bryan wanted to say
is that she's not going to be able to
win a battle against kuvira without
killing her like she'll have to go to
the Avatar State and she's not gonna be
able to do that just because she thinks
that she is another version of her so
she doesn't want to kill herself so when
it comes to fighting Cuvier a course at
a stalemate she's not gonna be able to
fight her because she can't kill her and
killing her is the only way to beat her
question number 6 choko Roco asks it
seems like korra is going to a big
temple soon why do you think she's going
there so there's two possibilities one
she just could be going to learn some
spiritual knowledge or if she could be
visiting Zaheer in prison I've seen a
lot of Zaheer theories I don't know that
he's being kept in the earth Kingdom
specifically but I think regardless of
who she's going to see she's going to
seek knowledge it's like when they went
to watch E tong's library in book 2 the
same thing happened during last year
bender this is always an episode where
the team goes to learn more information
about the problem the problem in book
for being Kuvera so think of it as
existential study time question number 7
Saint PS is this the last season of core
ever that sucks
yes it does suck but there are a lot of
TV shows that have continued on in the
comics like Smallville did a next season
in the comics Buffy the Vampire Slayer
did the same thing Korra could do the
same thing too I think the actual
stories they end up writing will be a
little bit smaller like the books
they've written for Last Airbender like
the collected works like the search the
promise the rift I think it'll be more
like that I mean as long as there's a
new arc a new story you can view that as
a new season so technically it might be
the last season on TV but it's not the
last season of Korra ever question
number 8 dawn asks do you think the
kuvira had good intentions when do you
think she went wrong so I think she
definitely started out with good
intentions she did the core thing where
she just wrote in gung-ho and tried to
solve the problem there was chaos all
over the earth Kingdom so I think that
her solution involved just completely
replacing their order with hers that's
what the contracts are you know you do
everything the way I tell you to do it
or else I think that started in Ba Sing
se I think that they wrote in there
first that would be where things went
wrong she equalized everyone in a very
Amman type of way it just didn't have to
do with bending and not bending so if
you want to pinpoint like a very
specific time in place where things went
horribly horribly wrong I would say the
minute she fixed you know fixed Ba Sing
se question number nine Kevin asks do
you think that Asami's father will help
them fight kuvira do you think that
vaatu will come back because of all the
spirit vine tech and do you think the
kuvira wants to kill Korra and try to
control the earth avatar that would take
her place
so a lot of questions okay so I
definitely think that Asami's father
will help out in some way maybe just
giving Asami advice she's really smart
so she could pretty much do almost
anything he can Mike and Bryan explained
at Comic Con that the Airbender costumes
are from future industries designed by
Asami so she is a capable engineer just
like her father he might not make it out
of prison but I do think that he'll be
able to give her some advice on how to
solve a few problems as for vaatu no
Mike and Bryan confirmed that it'll be
another 10,000 years before we see him
again
and as for kuvira controlling an earth
avatar i don't think that she wants
another avatar i think the technology is
one of the big villains in this book
like you have that giant high-speed rail
at the magnetic rail and now you're
gonna have the spirit vine tech i think
she intends for that to replace what the
avatar would normally do be like a giant
weapon it's funny how a lot of Korra's
enemies just view her as a giant weapon
or if not a weapon than a giant tool
question number 10 Jessica asked when do
you think the team quarrel will reunite
so I know that at least half of them
will reunite in the next episode but it
might be episode 8
they're all completely together there
are 13 episodes in the season and I
don't think they're gonna wait till
episode 13 to do like the big final
battle when they'll definitely all be
together I think there will be a
confrontation with kuvira's army again
even though Mike and Brian have said
that there's not gonna be like some
giant big core battle at the end usually
what you would see is a team core rally
before the climax kuvira needs to get
more spirit vines to replicate the
spirit vine weapon right now the only
place we know that they grow in
abundance is Republic City so it's
possible she could move her army on
Republic City to get more of that I
don't know that for sure it's possible
that spirit vines could be growing
embossing say but I just feel like
everything is pointing towards kuvira
moving on Republic City next thank you
so much though everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do again I think that there's a big
big climax coming for Korra so it will
get more exciting even if you weren't
big fans of this episode in particular
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner Daniel Kelly you win an Amazon
gift card just be sure to message me on
my channel or Twitter or Facebook or
somewhere for details
so just remember still a whole bunch of
stuff to look forward to big team Korra
reunion more Toph scenes and scenes with
Zuko's daughter
Azumi in the meantime you can click here
for my episode 6 video and click here
for my episode 5 video thank you so much
for watching so let's all high five and
I'll see you guys tonight
you
[Music]